Construyamos un ejemplo más de un diagrama de
Lewis que puede ser interesante. Digamos que
queremos construir la estructura o el diagrama
de Lewis del difluoruro de xenón. Así que pausa
el video e inténtalo. Muy bien, vamos a trabajar
juntos. El primer paso es contar los electrones
de valencia. El xenón, que tenemos por acá, es un
gas noble, tiene 8 electrones de valencia: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 en su quinta capa, ya que está
en el quinto periodo, así que tiene 8 electrones
de valencia. Por otra parte, sabemos que el flúor
-ya que con él hemos trabajado varias veces- tiene
7 electrones de valencia: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 en
su segunda capa; como tenemos 2 átomos de flúor,
tenemos 2 x 7. Y esto nos da un total de 8
+ 14 electrones de valencia, lo que es igual
a 22 electrones de valencia en total. Ahora,
el segundo paso, ya lo hemos trabajado varias
veces en distintos videos, es intentar dibujar la
estructura con algunos enlaces covalentes simples.
Pondremos al xenón como nuestro átomo central
ya que es menos electronegativo que el flúor
y pondremos los 2 átomos de flúor de cada lado:
uno aquí y otro acá, y asignemos algunos enlaces
covalentes simples. Entonces, ¿cuántos electrones
de valencia hemos asignado hasta ahora? Bueno, son
2 de este enlace y otros 2 de este otro enlace,
hemos asignado 4 de ellos; restamos 4 electrones
de valencia y nos quedaremos con un total de
18 electrones de valencia. El siguiente paso es
asignarlos a nuestros átomos terminales y tratar
de que completen su octeto. Cada uno de estos
átomos de flúor ya tiene asignados 2 electrones de
valencia que comparten, por lo tanto, necesitamos
asignarles otros 6 electrones de valencia a cada
uno de ellos: 2, 4, 6; 2, 4, 6. Así que hemos
asignado 2 electrones de valencia más, lo que
significa que todavía tenemos 6 electrones de
valencia restantes para asignar, y existe sólo un
lugar donde podemos colocar esos 6 electrones de
valencia restantes y es en el átomo central, en
el xenón, así que hagámoslo: 2, 4, 6. Y ya está,
hemos construido el diagrama o estructura de Lewis
para el difluoruro de xenón. Lo que es interesante
esta vez es que nuestros átomos de flúor tienen
un octeto de electrones de valencia. Pero ¿qué
pasa con el xenón? Bueno, el xenón tiene 2, 4,
6, 8, 10 electrones de valencia a su alrededor.
Así que este es un ejemplo de la excepción de
la regla del octeto, donde tenemos más de 8
electrones de valencia, lo que es posible para los
elementos que están en el tercer periodo o mayor.